[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui mais n'a pas ralenti c'est mélissa
mollen depuis sept semaines
édition spéciale bébé yoda pourquoi et
bien parce que dans les dernières
semaines on a eu énormément de diction
qui ont des hommes éditions qui divisait
qui séparait qui désunissaient justement
les nations autochtones et les
communautés à l'automne parce qu'on
parlait de racisme discrimination
systémique et que les gens ont
l'impression que ça nous éloignés les
uns des autres mais je pense qu'il faut
pas manquer de voir comment ces
discussions là seront aussi importants
pour nous rapprocher
mais cette semaine j'ai voulu parler
justement de ces choses qui nous
rapprochent beaucoup plus facilement et
culturellement c'est à dire ces moments
de culture populaire contemporain existe
pour nous permettre d'avoir un chemin
commun visuellement et culturellement
cependant tout en gardant son identité
culturelle pourquoi je parle de be2
c'est que l'année dernière quand des bio
dès la saison du mandat le rien est
sorti que cette semaine la deuxième
saison vient de sortir et bien la
discussion autour de la nation de
l'origine de la nation de bébé au dos a
fait le tour d'une nouvelle a fait le
tour des médias
et c'est devenu un sujet de conversation
extrêmement sympathique bien des gens
ont été issus des eaux commencent à
faire si vous avez des choses beaucoup
plus importantes à parler que les bio de
star wars
mais le truc c'est que nous on avait
besoin en parlant d'un besoin de s'unir
autour de sujets heureux joyeux un
échange un peu comme on fait quand on
fait des parois quand on voit des
émissions qu'on peut voir notre culture
rayonner sur la place publique
faut pas oublier que dans un contexte de
colonisation et bien nos cultures ont
été effacées nos cultures ont été
diminués on a eu de la misère à faire
entendre nos voix mais à travers un
point commun qui pouvait être reconnu
par des allochtones et bien on ne put
faire ressortir justement notre culture
au québec ce qui est amusant c'est que
il ya eu quand même une batterie assez
serré entre les attikameks et les innu
les innocents vraiment les la nation
d'origine de bébés yoda est ce que ça a
permis c'est de faire ressortir
justement la fierté culturelle la fierté
des origines est aussi une petite
bataille amical en outre les inouïes les
attire et qui sont quand même deux
nations voisines fusent il s'entend
quand même assez bien et qui aiment
cette technique et taquiner c'est une
manière de créer le lien dans beaucoup
de nations alors à travers des bo gars
aient bien on a pu créer ce moment là et
le faire rayonner pas uniquement les
communautés autochtones
on a pu voir au cours de l'année même si
d'autres mis une seconde
mêmes qui sont des rites culturels
communs j'ai pu passer a donc fait 80
qui lui a fait un vidéo qui donne
tellement virale que personne n'a pu
ignorer une vidéo d'un homme autochtone
qui boit du jus de canneberge en faisant
de la planche à roulettes tel manque ça
l'a fait ressurgir de la musique qui
n'était pas de musique autochtone mais
de la musique d'artistes allochtone et
fait ressurgir aussi la fierté d'être
notre cas dans l'attitude il avait ce
qui était drôle c'est que la lecture
qu'on en avait été très différente si on
n'était autre que nous allons pour un
attaquant c'est vraiment c'est le moment
qu'on a tous des super joyeux que y'en a
pas de problème qui le jus de canneberge
c'est comique parce que culturellement
on est très proche de cette savoir que
la canneberge ou le tous dans les
plantes traditionnelles et donc c'est un
serveur qu'on aime qui est pas tout un
goût de tout le monde et que le voir
boissons jus canneberge sur sa planche à
roulettes en faisant un clic top ça leur
fait éveillé chez nous on est encore là
on est encore joyeux on représente
encore les meilleures valeurs de notre
culture et ça leur fait résonner chez
les à l'otan au 6e sentiment de bassam à
ben ali et ça existe à plusieurs les
autres niveaux plusieurs même plusieurs
enjeux
et qui reçoit par exemple sur ce côté de
l'adoption ou d'adaptation culturelle
quand on a des misères avant cette
conversation aussi par rapport au fait
qu'on va parler des fois d'appropriation
culturelles ou de colonisation mais
cette fine line qui existent de la
relation qui peut se créer en deux
nations qui combinent leurs cultures
c'est à peu près comment les relations
se faisait autrefois et on a même dit
wang qun existe qui représente vraiment
très bien cette réflexion là c'est le
tout gros boum boum lorent wanson à deux
voix et ces deux canaux sur une même
rivière
vous devriez vous informer sur son
poulain énormément d'enseignements qui
peuvent en ressortir et c'est même
l'idée de pouvoir emprunter l'oeil de
quelqu'un d'autre pour voir les choses
c'est à voir avec deux yeux de deux
nations différents donc être capable de
garder son identité mais en partageant
la vision de l'autre et ça ça permettait
d'avoir deux nations totalement
différentes qui s'unissaient équipe
culturellement échange et c'est là aussi
où on a pu voir les créations des
paroles c'est lorsqu'on se rend compte
et c'est l'heure où ce qu'on peut
échanger sans vouloir faire disparaître
la culture de la font disparaître
l'identité de l'autre ça existe encore
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose quand
même d'ailleurs aidé beaucoup la culture
qui existent aujourd'hui je pense à la
grande grande échange de pandiani il ya
eu dans les années 70 où certaines
nations ont prêté des cérémonies ont
prêté des traditions à d'autres nations
puisqu'il avait été effacée par la
colonisation et ces cérémonies lieux qui
ont été donnés ou prêtés
eh bien elles ont servi comme un peu de
béquilles en attendant que les nations
puissent revenir vers des pratiques
qu'il ressemblait plus à leurs propres
pratiques historiques
donc il ya eu ces échanges là et on
continue d'en faire on continue d'avoir
des séries qui nous unissent qu'ils nous
font avoir du plaisir et qui nous
permettent de créer ce lien vers le
futur puisque contrairement à ce que
beaucoup de gens pensent la culture des
communautés autochtones continuent
d'évoluer constamment on est encore des
êtres vivants qui existe
dans cette modernité et on continue
d'apprécier les mêmes je pense que tout
le monde et de pouvoir échanger ensemble
donc je pense qu'il faut pas perdre de
vue que notre relation qu'elle est
extrêmement difficile qu'elle demande à
voir beaucoup de discussions beaucoup
des changes
elle crie quand même des nouvelles
choses qui ne peuvent pas être effacé de
l'histoire et qui vont permettre aussi
de faire rayonner la culture qui ont
malheureusement souffert justement la
colonisation et de l'effacement culturel
et près de donner envie aux gens de
s'informer sans nécessairement effacés
la voir et on peut faire de l'adoption
on peut faire de l'adaptation ça a été
fait par le passé on vous demande juste
de parfaire d'appropriation culturel et
je vous invite à continuer de vous
intéresser à comment aux combines au
futur ensemble d'ailleurs le 15 novembre
s'est rendu au max et sur les médias
sociaux vous pouvez voir des gens qui
portent leurs mocassins fièrement et ça
nous permet de comparer les modes les
motifs les modèles comment on l'est pas
et ça c'est un moment extrêmement fier
pour les gens de pouvoir montrer qu'ils
sont encore capables de fabriquer leurs
mocassins et de les porter donc je vous
invite à partager je vous invite
d'ailleurs à partager ses vidéos et je
voudrais une seule chose dans les mots
de l'autre cela est la voix